in the very first episode of NCIS titled
Yankee white the death of a marine on
Air Force One triggers a massive
jurisdictional complications the
question this episode raises is who
claims jurisdiction over the death of a
naval commander who dies on Air Force
One do Gibbs and his team have any right
to fly away with the president's plane
in order to hold such jurisdiction first
let's break the events of the episode
Down the second the president walks off
the plane the Secret Service loses
jurisdiction and it gets handed off to
the FBI hence FBI agent fornell's
Presence at the crime scene the
secretary of the Navy instructs that
since NCIS has a horse in the race in
the form of a dead officer they would
have jurisdiction to take custody of the
body in the real world however does that
really give them the right to snatch the
president's plane to ensure they keep
custody and if they can't take the plane
how is it that we never hear about
anyone getting in trouble for that stunt
thereafter